[موسيقى]
هذه
هي نهاية الطريق بالنسبة للإلكترونيات القديمة
أو ليس تمامًا ،
لذا هذا مثال على المخلفات الإلكترونية ، كل
هذه
أجهزة كمبيوتر محمولة بأفران ميكروويف ،
كل شيء يسير من هنا ،
هذه بداية العملية ،
فرصة جديدة للحياة لغير المرغوب فيها  أجهزة
كبلات الهواتف ، طابعات الهواتف ،
تأتي جميع أنواع المواد مثل
الجديدة جاهزة للاستخدام والتصنيع
مرة أخرى
تأتي هذه المواد من هذا
الهاتف وسنذهب لصنع هاتف جديد
مثل هذه
البيئة التي تجمع النفايات الإلكترونية للمزيد
أكثر من 10 دول في جميع أنحاء الشرق
الأوسط وأفريقيا مرة واحدة في منشأة
دبي التي تحتاج إلى إصلاح سريع ، يتم إصلاح
أي شيء مكسور
وإزالة بطارياتها وفصلها
بناءً على ما صنعت منه
كل منا ينتج في المتوسط سبعة كي
وغرامات من  النفايات الإلكترونية في
السنة تعادل ما يقرب من أربعة
أجهزة كمبيوتر محمولة لكل شخص على هذا الكوكب كل
عام ومن المتوقع أن تتضاعف بحلول عام 2050.
التخلص من كل هذه الأشياء ليس بالأمر السهل
أولاً  المخاطر الصحية
للتعرض للمواد السامة ، وإذا قمت
برميها في مكب النفايات ، فإن كل هذه
العناصر القيمة تذهب فقط لإهدار
النفايات الإلكترونية التي تذهب إلى مكب النفايات ليست
حلاً ، إنها متوقفة في وضع الخمول
للمستقبل عندما لا يعرف أحد
ما هو السبب في البيئة  عازمون على
توفير بديل
في الوقت الحالي ، فهم يعملون حاليًا
بسعة سبعة بالمائة فقط
ولكنهم يأملون في نهاية المطاف في معالجة 39000
طن من النفايات الإلكترونية كل عام
، لسنا بكامل طاقتنا
بالتأكيد ولكننا مستعدون للمستقبل حتى
نتمكن من  القيام بالمزيد والمزيد
حول العالم يتم إعادة تدوير أقل من 20 في المائة من
النفايات الإلكترونية بشكل صحيح
وفقًا لرصد النفايات الإلكترونية العالمي
وحاليًا فقط 10 مليار دولار أمريكي فقط
منكم تعلمون أنه يتم استرداد المواد الخام
من النفايات الإلكترونية وما يقرب من
مليار  لم يتم استردادها على الإطلاق ، لذا
هناك فرصة كبيرة للخروج من
النفايات الإلكترونية ، مثال على كيف
أن قمامة رجل ما هي كنز رجل آخر
Anna Stewart cnn
[موسيقى]